march 3rd uh we strongly condemn
the use of violence by burmese security
forces against
the burmese people including peaceful
protesters
to your point journalists and civil
society we
continue to urge the bernie bernie's
military to exercise
maxim maximum restraint this latest
escalation and violence
demonstrates the fact of the junta's
complete
disregard for their own people for
the people of burma it is unacceptable
and the world
will continue to respond the united
states will continue to respond we'll
continue to respond
uh in tandem uh with our partners and
allies around the world
we've said this before but it remains
true that tens of
thousands of burmese have courageously
taken to the streets peacefully to show
the strength of their will and the power
of their
collective voice we have sought uh again
with our partners and allies to
uh amplify the power of their collective
voice we call on the military to act
peacefully and with respect for human
rights including the freedom of
expression
and peaceful assembly these are two
universal rights that are as applicable
in burma
as they are anywhere else we will
continue as i said to work with the
international community
to take meaningful action against those
responsible
there will be additional action um on
the part of the united states
we support freedom of peaceful assembly
including
to protest peacefully in support of the
restoration of the democratically
elected government and matt you asked
about
the journalists uh that have been
detained so um allow me just just a
moment on that
um we are of course aware of the reports
uh that the military has charged
additional
journalists with crimes we are deeply
concerned
about the increasing attacks and on and
arrests of
journalists we call on the military to
immediately release these individuals
into cease
their intimidation and harassment of the
media
and others who are unjustly detained
for doing nothing more than their job
for doing nothing more
than exercising their universal rights
we've said this before in the context of
burma we've said it before in the
context of other
countries around the world but a free
and independent media it plays a
critical role in ensuring that people
are able to make informed decisions we
call upon the military to work
uh on the military to allow journalists
to work independently
and without harassment intimidation or
fear of reprisal
uh as i've said before we have taken a
number of actions against
the military punta against the military
leaders and military entities
responsible for the coup and for related
violence
including visa restrictions and asset
blocking
sanctions we will continue and expand
our efforts
to promote accountability for the
military's actions including
uh the detention of these journalists
and the heinous violence
uh that we've seen in burma in recent
days uh two
very brief things on this and then i'll
move on
i'll stop but uh one you know and the uh
the khashoggi ban right that obviously
was related to saudi arabia
but is that something that you're
considering uh
using in relation to burma
because of what you've just talked about
and then
and then just secondly you mentioned
twice that you're working
with partners and allies but what about
countries that might not necessarily be
partners
allies specifically china absolutely um
are you have you approached the chinese
about
maybe them using their influence
whatever
it is with the uh with the burmese
military
so in terms of your first question the
khashoggi ban we did unveil
uh this new policy of uh the department
of state and the united states
government in the context of
um our response to the gruesome heinous
murder of jamal khashoggi but a very
important point
khashoggi ban is as applicable uh to
uh saudi operations as it is to those
operations
targeting dissidents um the world over
um
the ban has uh global applicability
uh for countries uh who would uh pursue
uh dissidents political uh opponents
extra territorially
uh so if it is appropriate um if it is
relevant uh in this case
um we will not hesitate to apply it when
it comes to china
um let me first start by saying that as
you know and i say as i think as i
repeated yesterday
we have worked since february 1st since
the united states
declared the overthrow of the
democratically elected civilian
government in burma to be a coup
uh primarily with our like-minded
partners and allies our partners and
allies in the indo
pacific our treaty allies uh
institutions
uh like asean uh our allies in
europe uh with the g7 um
but this is a challenge where we have
sought to um
see to it that the world speaks in
with as close to one voice as possible
uh we have urged the chinese to play a
constructive
role to use their influence with
uh the burmese military to bring
this coup to an end as you know uh
secretary blinken has had an opportunity
to
speak to director yang uh president
biden has had an opportunity to speak to
president
xi uh there have been a number of
conversations
uh with chinese officials at different
levels uh and our message and all those
conversations
has been consistent the world
uh every responsible uh constructive
uh member of the international community
needs to use
its voice means to work uh to bring this
coup to an end and to restore the
democratically elected government
are you aware do you know when the last
conversation was with the
with the with the chinese about burma
specifically
we've we've read out many of these
conversations
some of them have taken place at very
senior levels others at
lower levels um but we've read out the
relevant ones
we'll move this way
since one of the journalists detains an
ap journalist in this american news
organization you kind of addressed this
a bit yesterday but
you know is there a specific uh
communication that you've made to the
burmese government or the embassy is
made to blow into government
to say you know we're concerned about
this journalist particularly
and we want to see what do you want to
see in that case
it's not always uh appropriate and it's
not always helpful
for us um to speak to specific cases
oftentimes we can't
speak to specific cases out of privacy
concerns
as well but the burmese military should
have no doubt
and i can assure you has no doubt about
where the united states stands when it
comes to these
these unjust detentions i have just
repeated it now
uh we have made it clear um in uh voices
that are certainly much more senior
uh than mine um from this government uh
and so there's no doubt when it comes to
burmese authorities yes um with respect
the u.s
action so far does not seem to have
deterred or
caused the military hunter to change
course
so what more do you think you could do
when u.s sanctions
don't really have much of a reach there
and when it comes to china
let's say any other country but china
seems to have the most influence is
there a specific action you want to see
from them
what action could they take that you
think would have the most impact
in trying this well i would say a couple
things number one
when it comes to american actions uh
the this continues to develop um
the the the full story is yet unwritten
uh in terms of our policy response and i
um expect and i am confident that you
will see
us take additional policy moves to
hold to account those responsible for
this coup in burma for
the overthrow of burma's civilian and
democratically elected government
in some ways though the more important
point is what we are doing
with our partners and allies around the
world uh
we know that as the most powerful
country in the world what we do matters
uh what we do will have uh important
impact
uh but when we work with our partners
and allies
uh using uh working with them
cooperating with them
um as force multipliers as the secretary
has put it
uh that we can bring to bear um much
more uh
influence and sway um regardless of the
challenge and that includes
uh when it comes to holding to account
those responsible for
uh this coup in burma i mentioned this
yesterday um
but a couple of our close partners
including the brits
the british government and the canadian
government have announced
sanctions their own sanctions uh against
uh burmese authorities we continue
uh burmese military punta i should say
uh
we continue to work with primarily with
our like-minded partners and allies
around the world to speak with one
collective voice and to
act collectively to hold to account
those responsible for this when it comes
to china our message has been
very clear china needs to be a
constructive
responsible actor when it comes to
the military coup in burma uh of course
there was
a statement that emanated from the u.n
security council several weeks ago now
that no country including china stood in
the way of uh
we would like to see responsible uh
actors
and parties around the world including
the chinese uh continue
to condemn this to condemn this
forcefully uh
and to use uh appropriate uh policy
responses to hold to account those
responsible for this
look it's not up to us to dictate what
any other country does
uh but we have made very clear uh to
countries around the world
our close partners and allies uh and our
competitors
uh uh our chief competitor in the case
of china um
what we think uh a responsible and
constructive
uh response might look like yes
or should we move on uh iran sure
it will start with iran and then we'll
go there okay thank you um
i was wondering if the u.s regrets to
withdrawal of the european
resolution in in to censor iran in
vienna
or if you see it as a good way to allow
diplomacy to happen
the meeting to happen well i would say
uh just first of all that
iaa director grossi uh offered a
proposal
for iran to address unanswered concerns
uh regarding its nuclear program the e3
decided
with the uh full support of the united
states
that the best way to support the iaea's
process
was to refrain from putting forward the
draft resolution at the meeting
of the board of government governors we
are pleased
with the outcome of the iaea board of
governors meeting with respect
to iran the proposal that was put
forward by director
uh grassy um uh were
um uh
we supported um uh the e3
um we supported it um we also
recognized that the director general has
put forward a realistic schedule
which we understand iran has accepted
when it comes to
the next steps and we will look forward
with strong interest
for iran's willingness to engage in a
way that leads to
credible concrete uh progress uh on
these issues
french diplomats told us in paris today
that they are now
quite optimistic that the meeting
including the us and iran could happen
in the next couple of weeks in brussels
do you share this feeling do you have
some
feedback about that what we've
consistently said about this is that
we are neither optimistic nor
pessimistic
we are clear-eyed when it comes to our
diplomacy knowing that we
are engaging in this with our
closest partners the e3
in this case uh knowing that um we have
put
a proposition on the table both a
strategic proposition
uh the shorthand for which is compliance
for compliance
uh if iran resumes its full compliance
uh with the jcpoa uh the united states
will be
prepared uh to do the same as well as a
tactical proposition and that tactical
proposition was one we first talked
about
last month uh that if the eu put forward
an imitation
the united states would be prepared to
accept in the context
of talks direct talks with iran and
the p5 plus one again we're not dogmatic
about the format
what we are dogmatic about is our
overarching objective and that is to
ensure
that iran is subject to permanent
verifiable restrictions that prevent
iran from ever obtaining a nuclear
weapon
at such a meeting between iran and the
u.s
are you ready to negotiate the
synchronized
steps by the u.s and iran to come back
in compliance is that the idea
what we are ready to do waiting to know
if you're ready to negotiate
well for nice steps uh iran should not
be waiting for anything because we have
uh stated very clearly
that what we are prepared to do is to
engage in constructive dialogue
that is the offer that has been on the
table i know that
various proposals and ideas have been
put forward from
various capitals uh the proposal that we
have put forward
that the e3 has uh uh accepted
and endorsed that the eu uh has now put
forward its own offer
is to take part in principled clear-eyed
constructive negotiations
in the context of the p5 plus one with
the iranians
where we can discuss the very issues
that
might be at play again
if there are other proposals for formats
we are open to those but uh what we are
going to be rigid about um
is our recognition about what we seek
and that is very simple
um permanent verifiable limits uh on
iran's nuclear program limits that
permanently prevent iran from ever
attaining a nuclear weapon
secretary clinton yesterday talked about
the
two foreign policy achievements under
obama biden administration one was the
iran deal
are you at all worried that this sort of
you go first and getting entangled
in who takes the first step will result
in and
precious time loss in the class of a
deal
under your watch something that didn't
happen under trump administration even
though they tried very hard
are you worried about that well i i
think i would take issue with the
premise of the question
it was under uh it certainly hasn't been
since january 20th
uh that the united states has uh
uh withdrawn from the deal it's certain
has certainly hasn't been since january
20th
uh that iran has distanced itself uh
from
uh the uh requirements imposed by the
jcpoa
uh what we are concerned about um
uh is um uh
is the idea uh that iran would
remain unconstrained uh by nuclear
limits
limits that are verifiable limits that
permanently prevent iran from obtaining
a nuclear weapon that is why
um we are approaching this challenge
with urgency
uh that is why from essentially day one
uh we have taken on the task
of undertaking those consultations with
partners
with allies with members of congress
that culminated a couple weeks ago now
um in our offer um that the eu
uh put forward uh to take part in direct
talks with the iranians in the context
of
the p5 plus one uh so look i think when
you
uh if you want to dissect what happened
with the jcpoa
uh you have to start well before uh
january 20th what we are focused on
uh is ensuring that we get back to a
point
where iran is permanently and verifiably
constrained
and to a point where iran can never
acquire or produce a nuclear weapon
deputy secretary likely incoming
secretary ambassador sherman
said in 2009 i would be shocked if iran
agreed to meeting without some
sanctioned relief
how is what makes you think that is not
the case now
2009 uh is very different from
19 19 i'm sorry
i'm sorry i misheard you um look the the
point we have been making
uh is the point i would remind you of
and namely that there have been various
proposals
that have been put on the table we feel
that the best place to
address those proposals is in direct
diplomacy uh with the iranians that we
are willing
to undertake in the context of the p5
plus one
the eu has offered to convene these
talks we had accepted
uh that invitation i understand we are
um still waiting to hear
from the iranians but all these
questions
uh about the details behind the
strategic proposition that president
biden has put forward
this proposition of compliance for
compliance the best place to address
that
uh is through the context of diplomacy
restriction because absent in these
conversations is the impact of the
previous administration's policy on the
iranian people
other than sanctions you know the ban
the muslim ban has been removed but a
lot of other policies
remain one of which is washington post
reported a few days ago
the people with many young men in iran
are forced to
to do their military service in irgc
and since the designation there's a
letter from u.s embassy in dubai in abu
dhabi telling
one american who's trying to bring his
uh her
husband to the united states that you
you know you did the military service in
rgc therefore
you cannot join your wife and your child
there seems to be
a continuation of implementation of
those policies on the trump
administration
is there any review for cases like this
where ordinary people are getting caught
up in in policies that
uh you know remain in on the books well
i couldn't speak to any specific case
nor would it be appropriate for me to do
so what i would say
is that and i've said this in the in
other contexts as well
that we can do a couple things at the
same time when it comes to a run
we can seek to ensure as we are doing
that iran
can never be allowed to acquire or
produce
a nuclear weapon just as we put pressure
on iran's uh continuing support for
uh terrorism and terrorist groups
throughout the region uh we can do
those two things uh simultaneously and
in fact
uh our principles uh clear-eyed pursuit
of a um means to verifiably and
permanently prevent iran from obtaining
a nuclear weapon
that in turns that in turn allows us to
take on
uh in a more effective way other areas
of iran's malign activity
and influence every challenge we face
with iran would be compounded would be
all the more
difficult if iran were on the precipice
of
producing a nuclear weapon if iran were
on the precipice of producing a nuclear
weapon or
certainly if iran over time
were able to cross that precedence we
are committed to
preventing that um we are committed to
preventing that for
our own national security for the
national security of our uh close
partners and allies in the region but
also because
uh we know that all of these challenges
would become more difficult
and more complex uh and the idea that we
have talked about going beyond
this idea of compliance or compliance
going beyond this idea of lengthening
and strengthening the nuclear agreement
is the idea that uh the
mutual return to the jcpoa is necessary
but in the long term it's insufficient
it's insufficient because of iran's
continuing malign influence and malign
activities in the region and that's why
using the stronger and longer jcpoa as a
platform
we ultimately seek to negotiate uh
follow-on agreements that address some
of these areas of concern
and of course iran's continued support
for terrorism throughout the region is a
profound
concern of the united states and our
partners nowadays
yes yes about the national security
strategy or the interim guidance
it seems to differ from the past
national security strategies in terms of
making china the primary global threat
russia seems to be you know secondary
uh it doesn't have the sort of global
language about about russia that seems
to reflect what the us
has uh focused on lately which is china
the last few years
our question is how does um secretary
blinken plan to uh follow that
does that mean in regions like europe
where there are priorities related to
china priorities related to russia that
the one related to china will take
precedence
there's some things you know you know
nordstrom stream two
if that's an issue with russia does that
need to be patched up so that we can
work together in china
in the middle east or africa where china
and russia are both active is it more
important to counter china is it in
other words will this document be
something that's acting on it
and how that works in the secretary's
diplomacy well i think it's fair to say
that uh the white house
wouldn't have put out this document and
secretary lincoln wouldn't have
previewed it in his speech yesterday
if it's not something uh we don't seek
to adhere to
um something that we don't seek to
follow through on uh even before we get
to china
i think i would be remiss if i didn't
mention uh one of the defining features
uh of this document one of the defining
features uh in secretary blinken's
remarks
yesterday um and that is that uh the
foreign policy vision
that president biden has set out and and
really our
north star uh in executing it um
is a vision of foreign policy that
delivers
for the american people uh at every step
of the way at
every crossroads uh we seek uh to
make their lives more secure create
opportunities
for them and their families and to
tackle the global crises
that are increasingly shaping their
futures i believe the national security
advisor
has put it this way that there's one
simple question
we should ask ourselves uh at every
single policy decision is what we are
doing
making the lives of the american people
people safer
easier and better and that's precisely
what this policy
uh sets out it seeks to bridge uh that
long-standing
um and in some cases wide chasm chasm
between
domestic policy uh and foreign policy
now one of those issues that is really
at the nexus
of the domestic in the floor and it's
china um and that it of course
is because china is uh fundamentally a
competitor of ours it is a competitive
relationship
it is a relationship that has
adversarial elements that we all know
about
uh it is a relationship that uh when
it's in our interest uh can have
uh cooperative uh elements and i think
the fact that
uh one of the priorities uh that
secretary blinken laid out
um uh in his speech yesterday um he did
mention
managing the biggest geopolitical test
of the 21st century
our relationship uh with china uh you
didn't see other countries
uh enumerated on his list of priorities
in precisely the same way
because china is a strategic competitor
that crosses virtually every realm
the economic realm the security realm uh
the technological
realm uh i
our shared climate uh weapons of mass
destruction
uh the indo-pacific uh region itself
um and so it is a challenge i think that
in many ways is qualitatively
different uh from the other specific
challenges that we have now that's not
to say
that we don't face threats from russia
and in fact we do
i we of course uh just this week
spoke about our actions against uh
russian
government entities for uh their grave
violation
of human rights of their own citizens uh
the director of national intelligence
is undertaking a number of reviews
into russia's
malfeasance uh including its
interference in our elections uh the
reports of bounties on
american service members in afghanistan
uh the solar winds
uh cyber security breach so um
uh we are clear-eyed about the threat
that russia poses um
and russia also uh seeks to gain
influence in regions that are
uh somewhat farther afield um from the
russian federation
uh but uh russia doesn't pose
or have the capability have the ability
i should say to pose quite the same
challenge
uh that china does uh given the way in
which
the china challenge um
is uh transcends uh i would say these
various realms
uh in ways that uh other uh
country-specific threats don't always do
so does that mean like in region x when
it comes to china the secretary will
follow the course that is most useful in
competing with china and region x rather
than whatever
whatever other influences no i i i think
that the way to think about it
is that the secretary or the president
in region x y or z
will pursue what's in our interests and
what's consistent with our values
uh and in many cases um what is in our
interest and consistent with our values
uh will be to um push back on uh
adventurism on the part of russia or
china
um uh but i would hesitate to apply a
cookie
cookie cutter model to it um because
each uh
situation each region is going to be uh
somewhat different um what isn't
different is that across the globe
we recognize this competitive
relationship with china our strategy is
one that seeks to compete
and to out compete with the chinese
across the board
and to what the secretary said yesterday
to what the interim guidance
said yesterday we do that knowing that
we have these unique
sources of strength that truly uh no
other
country around the world does it's our
values it's our system of alliances
and partnerships um but it is also our
sources of domestic strength
uh what we bring to the table uh as the
american people
from our innovation from our creativity
from our vibrant economy
um and those are sources of strength uh
that china can't match that russia
can't match uh and that when we bring
them fully to bear
um that task of competing and ultimately
out competing
uh with beijing becomes all the more
achievable
and the first question was more stream
two um
and i'm just curious there's another
report today about uh
yet more ships or
a a another ship that was not
sanctioned but that is involved in
laying the pipeline and i'm just
wondering the secretary's supposed to go
up to the hill next week
to the house foreign affairs committee
are you asking a question are you
looking for wanting to know if he's
going to be able to tell them
anything about adding additional
sanctions
on two and i i see nick is standing up
we still have a lot of other stuff to go
through including yemen
lebanon refugees um
and i also have a question on bahrain so
maybe he should sit down because you're
gonna have to go through all of it
assume whatever posture he would like uh
so on
uh nordstrom 2 uh we have spoken about
the report that we submitted to congress
in
recent days that report to congress um
did detail the sanctionable uh activity
of
uh kbt ruse an entity knowingly selling
leasing or providing the vessel for tuna
for the construction
of uh the nordstream to pipeline it was
the department's analysis and
determination that the fortuna
was engaged in just the sort of activity
that was prescribed
in the affecting europe's energy
security act
or pisa now of course this is not the
end of the story
uh every 90 days we are
required to provide congress with an
update of our analysis and our
determination
of relevant and applicable sanctionable
activity um in the context of nordstream
ii uh so again if we determine that
other entities
are engaging in sanctionable activity um
as outlined
uh in uh by pisa um
uh the congressional uh legislation we
will report that to congress going
forward i believe the next report is due
to congress in may
yeah there's another police peace guy
my bloomberg colleagues had a story
earlier today saying the administration
is thinking about sanctioning the
central bank chief can you
uh speak to whether that's the case and
also
whether the state department remains
concerned about
what appears to be uh you know continued
uh pro protests obviously but also
concerns about corruption and
embezzlement
in lebanon so your second question uh we
are closely monitoring
the situation in lebanon we and our
international partners we have
repeatedly
underscored both publicly and privately
uh the urgency for lebanon's political
leaders
uh to finally act upon the commitments
they made to form a credible
and effective government the united
states supports the lebanese people
in their continued calls for
accountability uh and the reforms needed
to realize
economic opportunity better governance
and an end
to the endemic corruption much of which
has fueled what we've seen
in lebanon in recent days i wouldn't
want to get ahead of things i wouldn't
want to
preview or speak to any potential policy
uh
responses at this time i guess follow
sure uh leo nakamura from japan's nikkei
newspaper
thank you very much for taking my
question uh several questions
uh there are rebels the secretary
bringing
will visit japan and the
u.s and japanese governments are
considering
uh having learned two plus two
everyday uh their diary
in japan could you confirm this report
i'm not in a position to confirm any
reports of travel at this time i think
what is true
uh and what i can confirm is our deep
commitment to the indo-pacific region
uh obviously the secretary has had an
opportunity to speak uh with many of
our our close counterparts including our
treaty allies uh in the region
other partners uh in the region i think
you'll get you'll see us continue to
demonstrate
uh our commitment to the indo-pacific
going forward
i would ask you about the importance of
in-person meeting uh in the u.s
diplomacy
what do you think is the difference
between in-person meeting
and bachelor meeting in terms of
messaging
do you regret in-person meeting as a
better way to demonstrate
the the strength of the
u.s strength of partnership with
american allies
it's a it's a really interesting
question and it's one we've we've
thought about
obviously the pandemic in our current
reality poses any number of challenges
um for daily life but also for the
conduct of
uh diplomacy it has uh heretofore
prevented us
um from uh from the secretary
traveling around the world i know that
the secretary has been
uh itching to get on the road um
and to conduct that diplomacy in person
but of course our
priority is not only to the health
and safety of our own
staff but also to those with whom we
would come
into contact and so of course we are
cognizant
to ensure that we are operating
consistent uh with relevant
uh guidelines i think at the same time
uh the pandemic does also
afford us opportunities or at least the
opportunity to explore
new diplomatic opportunities uh and you
saw the secretary do that uh last week
when he embarked on his first virtual
trip
uh to mexico and canada it would have
been a very long day
uh had secretary blinken physically
traveled to both mexico and canada
uh last friday um but he was able to
engage in
bilateral diplomacy uh with our north
american partners
uh from the confines of the benjamin
franklin room um
it was a long day anyway that's that's
true uh not quite as long so
we are looking for ways to take
advantage
of technology where appropriate i think
over the longer term
no one is under the illusion that
technology is going to be a substitute
nor should it
for the conduct of face-to-face
diplomacy
but uh we have been trying to
make lemonade out of the linens that uh
the pandemic has uh
delivered to us uh yes
um these have now claimed another attack
on saudi arabia
do you expect the recent sanctions on
the two houthi leaders this week
will do anything to deter them i mean
the criticism being that
it just survived their own fault
well um uh you're right that we will
continue to hold the houthi leadership
uh to account for their reprehensible
conduct including for
um continued uh attacks against uh our
saudi partners i think over the longer
term uh what not only the united states
um but also saudi arabia and other
countries
uh in the region recognize um what we
certainly recognize
uh is that there is not a military
solution
to the conflict uh in yemen i think that
is growing uh increasingly clear
the world over um it is precisely why uh
president biden in one of his first
major national security appointments as
president uh appointed
tim linderking as a special envoy uh for
yemen it is precisely why tim linderking
has been on the road for much of his
time in that
role to support in large part what
u.n special envoy martin griffiths uh
has sought to do
um and so i think uh
just as we continue to put pressure on
the houthi leadership
um we are going to continue to work with
all
relevant parties um to see to it that we
can
achieve a durable and a lasting um
uh first a ceasefire in a durable and
lasting
uh political settlement um ultimately
that is what will bring
an easing of the humanitarian suffering
to the people of yemen
and what will um also i think lead to
a more stable uh yemen and uh ultimately
a more
secure saudi arabia as well yes
the prime minister's office announced
yesterday that they are investigating
what they say are credible
uh reports of atrocities do you think
that is enough you previously
called for an independent international
investigation
do we think that is enough that they
would conduct well we have repeatedly
engaged the ethiopian government on the
importance of ending the violence
ensuring unhindered humanitarian access
to tigre and
allowing a full independent
international investigation
into all reports of human rights abuses
we also noted
the commitments the public commitments
that the prime minister
uh had made uh in recent days uh
secretary
lincoln spoke to the prime minister
earlier this week on tuesday i believe
it was
uh and the readout of that call noted
that secretary blinken
raised uh prime minister abby's own
commitments i think what we're going to
look to um uh are both the right words
but of course even more importantly
uh the follow-through uh and it's that
follow-through that is important for us
see precisely because it is that
follow-through that will be so important
um to end the plight of
the people of t great put an end to
these reports of
terrible human rights abuses that have
plagued that region in recent weeks
you've said that atrocities have been
committed by multiple parties in your
read out on tuesday your statement over
the weekend can you be more specific in
terms of
who you believe are committing these
atrocities and if not
why wouldn't you name names uh well
there have been a number of reports that
have emerged uh a number of credible
public
uh reports um before we um
uh rather than um uh uh
speak to that at this moment we've
called on all relevant parties
um to um ensure that
these atrocious human rights abuses come
to an end
uh we've been clear um uh that eritrean
troops
uh need to need to leave um that
uh
that these abuses on all sides need to
come to an end
to leave do you believe that they are in
part responsible for some of these
atrocities
uh again uh we've seen multiple reports
of these atrocities
it's increasingly clear that what has
transpired in tigre
has been reprehensible and so our
focus is on bringing this conduct to an
end
that's why we've engaged in multiple
levels including recently with the prime
minister of ethiopia himself
uh to see to it that humanitarian access
uh
is allowed and to see to it that um the
ethiopian government
and to call on all sides to do all they
can
uh to bring the suffering into the
people of degrades yes
sorry just one last one um the the eu
has named a special envoy and they've
uh made the decision to withhold aid to
ethiopia over all of this
why haven't you taken similar steps uh
well we have taken
uh steps that are very much in line with
what you have heard from the eu to bring
an
end to the reported human rights human
rights abuses uh
in tgrip um we are we have been very
clear
in our words we have been very clear um
in our private words
uh with um relevant uh parties as well
um uh and i think you will see a
continued focus on the part of this
administration
uh on tigre given the um
atrocious reports that have continued to
emanate from the region
either requested access to that region
or been granted access to that region so
the usaid
u.s agency for international development
issued a statement earlier this week i
believe it was
noting that they are sending a disaster
assistance response team or dart
to tigre um so we are very much engaged
in doing all we can to facilitate and to
provide some of this humanitarian relief
to the people there
yes um it's been a while for
ceasefire to stay in effect but see
peace is tenuous and i'm curious if
you've had
any specific conversations what
secretary blinken is going to do
to ensure or try to ensure that uh the
ceasefire maintains
well um i think we said this yesterday
um but it is true that we have continued
to follow very closely
uh developments in jammu and kashmir our
our policy towards the region
has not changed we call on all parties
to reduce tensions along the line of
control
uh by returning to the 2003 ceasefire
ceasefire commitments we condem
terrorists who seek to infiltrate
across the line of control when it comes
to how we will support that
um we continue to support direct
dialogue
between india and pakistan on kashmir
and other areas of concern
leaders who feel restless in the process
is the united states going to do
anything to actually engage not just
the officials from the indian and
pakistani official delegations but
kashmiris within
um within the contested region to see
what they
what you can do to help elevate their
voices in the solution
i don't have anything in for you on that
if there's anything you have we will
um yes please i would like to ask about
brazil uh
secretary blinken has already spoken
with minister anastadio
but i would like to know when president
biden will
speak to president bolsonaro well i
wouldn't be in a position to
preview any calls any potential calls on
the part of the white house
um i think what is true um uh pertains
to our partnership with brazil
um our two centuries of that partnership
um have been and remain today important
to both our nations
and to our hemisphere brazilian united
states are the region's largest
democracies and the largest
economies we share commitment to
democratic values
we work together to address the most
urgent global
and regional challenges of the 21st
century our partnership is important to
both our nations and the entire region
in fact
and it's based on shared commitments to
democratic values that again
span nearly uh two single centuries
also the brazilian foreign minister said
this week that president bolsonaro will
make efforts to attend their summit in
april
so i'd like to ask what kind of
commitment does the united states
expect from brazil for brazil to make
during that meeting
uh well that is obviously for brazil
to decide to announce themselves uh i
think what
is true is that the president uh
secretary of state
uh special envoy for climate uh john
kerry uh they're focused on
advancing action at home uh and around
the world
to reach net zero emissions globally by
mid-century
and to keep the limit of 1.5 degrees
celsius average temperature increase
within reach and when in order to
achieve that goal
partnering with brazil is critical to
effectively tackling
uh the shared global challenge of
climate change
we hope to expand on our track record of
cooperation
uh with brazil and see brazil take
additional concrete steps uh towards
combating climate change
uh in achieving net zero emissions by
2015.
one last question does the u.s
government see the current state of the
pandemic in brazil as a threat
well we see the pandemic around the
world um
uh in every country as a potential
threat uh and it is
precisely because um as long as the
pandemic
continues uh to uh rage
uh no one can be safe from it uh as we
have seen with the development of
variance
various variants around the world until
the pandemic is controlled until it is
contained we can't achieve our end goal
of putting
this pandemic to an end that is
precisely why on his first day in office
president biden reengaged with the world
health organization
recognizing that again this is one of
those challenges that the united states
can put a dent in but we can't
certainly solve on our own it's
precisely why
you heard from president biden of our uh
four billion dollar
commitment to the kovacs facility
including two billion dollars
uh in the near term uh knowing that uh
for the united states in the first
instance we're focused on
getting a safe and effective vaccine to
millions of americans here at home but
there's also a broader tax and americans
won't be safe
no other country will be safe as long as
the pandemic continues
uh to spiral and that's what we seek to
put it into
helping brazil with that with vaccines
as well well again uh we have uh been
engaged with the international community
we have re-engaged with who we have made
a substantial
uh commitment to the kovacs facility in
the first instance in the form of two
billion dollars uh
so uh we are doing what we can to
alleviate this
uh the wha mission to to wuhan to
investigate
the origins of the of the virus
there's reporting in the wall street
journal today that they're considering
not even publishing the insurance report
on that um
at the time you said that you were
waiting to see the data
did you ever get the full data from uh
from that team and
there's also calls today for a new
international inquiry basically
start again because this one doesn't
seem to have been given access
in the right way does the us support
that
well we haven't seen uh the findings in
question of course aware of the report
that the findings that the interim
findings
won't be released publicly
what we've made clear for several weeks
now is that
we have deep concerns about the way in
which
the early findings of the kobit 19
investigation were
communicated and questions about the
underlying
process used to reach them we believe
and you saw a statement from the
national security advisor to this effect
a couple weeks ago now that it's
imperative
that this report uh be independent with
expert findings free from intervention
or alteration by chinese
government authorities and to better
understand this pandemic and prepare for
the next one
we know and we continue to call upon
china to make available its data
from the earliest days of the outbreak
the important point here is that it is
not
just about understanding uh what happens
uh uh when it comes to the origins of
this pandemic it is about
learning and doing being positioned to
do everything
we can to protect ourselves uh the
american people
and the international community against
pandemic threats
going forward that's why we need this
understanding that's why we need
um this transparency from the chinese
government
i think you can dispatch with very
quickly one is on bahrain yesterday
uh we spent a lot of time talking about
the middle east here uh yesterday there
was a letter that was sent to the
secretary by some
human rights groups about the situation
in bahrain
which has not come up in this briefing
and i'm just wondering one if you are
aware that the letter has been received
and
secondly whether or not it has been
received or not
is the situation in bahrain something
this administration is taking
a close look at and then secondly uh on
refugee admissions um there are reports
today there's one on cnn about
refugees who were booked on flights to
come
even including today uh but because the
presidential determination has not yet
been sent
the hill uh they were basically removed
from these flights so i'm just wondering
if you can update us
on one if you're aware of those these
reports
and two what if anything is being done
thanks uh when it comes to buffering um
and we've made the point
um uh which applies to bahrain equally
as it does
any other country uh that the united
states we bring our values with us
uh in the context of every uh bilateral
relationship
that includes uh with our close uh
security partners it includes
um with countries with whom we have a
strategic partnership um
i would need to get back to you as to
whether the secretary has
received that letter um but of course
human rights
in the middle east and beyond will
continue to be at the center of our
policy we've talked about that
in different contexts to date but it
applies equally
across the board when it comes to
refugees of course the president
believes secretary
lincoln um believes that it is very much
in our dna to be a country that welcomes
those fleeing persecution
welcomes those uh fleeing violence uh
the world over it's precisely
uh why discriminatory travel bans were
done away with it's precisely why
the president spoke early on of his
commitment to
the united states refugee program i
don't have any updates for you
uh in terms of our efforts to uh undo
some of the damage uh to that program um
but uh i'm
i'm sure we'll be in touch with you
aware of these reports about people who
are supposed to
come even today and not bumped off i
would need to look into it um okay i
think
uh we'll call today thank you very much
we'll see everyone tomorrow
um
record look we don't have any travel to
announce
at the moment it's certainly impossible
that
we're comfortable with
okay yeah
um in terms of a broad review
i wouldn't have immediate expectations i
think
that's a um cool have a good one thanks
a lot man
you got it see you tomorrow it's a
virtual briefing tomorrow for a counter
so you have whatever you
can be here yeah so will there be a
monitor up or something
um
go to the cafeteria hang out because
it's not happening in here they just do
it over the phone um
all of these are things in case
something pops up that's my job
there you go everybody's got to be
somewhere and you know what when
some of the guys they get this
assignment the previous administration
they just hung out outside the car yeah
and they never checked continuity
off cup of coffee but i've got all my
expenses and all my other admin drawn
slots
um
but i i'm also not sure it's just one um
that is a
okay well if they've announced it
oh okay okay
all right thanks everyone
how are you i'm good to you yeah